viii assertive isms existentialism there
they are
the quintessential existentialists
lounging in a Parisian left-bank cafe
discussing the meaninglessness of life
there is some truth behind every detail
of this stereotype but in its totality
it's a misleading caricature he knows
much too jean-paul Sartre and Albert
Camus both philosophers writers and
famous public intellectuals in France
from the Second World War
until Arthur's death in 1980 South
argued that the fundamental principle of
existentialism is that existence
precedes essence in other words we have
to create our own lives our own selves
our own values God does not exist
we are born without a destiny it's all
up to us we are therefore condemned to
be free condemned because our freedom is
far from that of the carefree hedonistic
consumed on a shopping spree we have an
absolute responsibility for ourselves
which can lead to despair and anguish
even questioning the point of living a
classic existential crisis this
existential angst has not gone away it's
the human condition as real today as
ever political freedom and material
prosperity and the struggle for basic
existence and survival but only increase
the struggle to find genuine meaning for
our existence why are we here how can we
make a difference how should we really
live southla took our freedom is given
but his partner and fellow philosopher
Simone de Beauvoir pointed out this not
always that simple in her seminal book
the second sex she argued the society
and political structures often conspire
to hold women back Camus argued that yes
we are free but the world itself is
absurd he be told the classical myth of
Sisyphus condemned ever to push a rock
up a hill only to see it roll back down
to him to start all over again like
Sisyphus our task is to accept our own
absurd lives cheerfully wonderful though
life can be it has no ultimate purpose
and we all end as dust however not all
existentialists believe we live in a
godless senseless universe
the father of existentialism the 19th
century Dame søren kierkegaard believed
in the Christian God but argued reason
and evidence can never prove that he
exists we have to take a non rational
leap of faith at its heart then
existentialism is not really all about
meaninglessness it's about the
responsibility we all have to make the
right choices in life both for ourselves
and for others a heavy responsibility
indeed and just as important now as in
post-war Paris